here's a guy right here knows what's up
oh yeah like this tattoo is definitely
looks like the outtake the eastbound and
down Brendan do coming at you from the
great state of Maine got like four days
of summer up here close so we're
celebrating the king of sticking for you
that Flay debris pool hitter
I'd be rocking a cute King and sting
suit grass clippings and all redneck
good time
gags great shades inflatable pool those
were dope I love them alright do I love
them too who's playing as a kid they're
so fun if somebody had an inflatable
pool man that [ __ ] was live right we
thought they're rich dude when I lived
in South Carolina in Charleston
they had this dude mr. Larry he was like
the landlord or whatever and we just
thought he was like some [ __ ] guy
that bothered us you know and on this
place had like three stories and the top
story had like a little porch and we
bought a wet pool what is it called
wettable inflatable pool yeah and put it
out there on the porch it feels like
water who like a wet pool hmm so then we
all sat in a - we're sitting like and
literally the kitchen the wall in the
kitchen is cracking because we didn't
think that we're putting all this water
it took like 25 minutes to fill it up oh
yeah so it's on the top of the kitchen
on this like a little patio and uh it
costs about six thousand dollars
everything and dude look he was a from
the ground he looked up at us and saw us
all cuz it was either your swimming or
you guys are not straight guys
and this was still a time when it was
just kind of wild to just it come out of
the closet from the third story of a
building with to your friends you know
and so we're like nope
so dude he comes storming in the
apartment you can hear him going up the
different level and we're literally push
the side and just flowing all this water
and he busted a man in the whole kitchen
wall crack today's portable pools slip
and slide oh I love the above-ground
pool and dad what pretend he was getting
like in the deep end whatta now you know
and the mom would leave
[Music]